où
[Musique]
e
le
[Musique]
pour assurer à ses passions dont
provident
s'il ya autre variation ce soir au
spectre sont montrés conclure et la
datar ans les pathologies typique de
l'encours est examinée ici ce sont les
l'exhortent le plastique c'est
l'accident décollage pendant la période
mais
voilà
nous avons une équipe chirurgicale
complète c'est-à-dire un survient un
médecin anesthésiste une infirmière
service de cette façon et une infirmière
de porc savons tous qu'il faut propos
c'est eric et d'autres matériels dans
les conditions de la celtic chercheurs
[Musique]
et
e
non
[Musique]
le coût social de cette mesure ne doit
pas être négligée ne doit pas être
sous-estimée
je ne suis donc pas certaine que ce soit
aujourd'hui la mesure la plus adaptée
vous territoire via les je n'écarte pas
ce stade l'hypothèse du retournement
total dernier robin si l'impact des
mesures de freinage de la décider de ce
qu'on fait ce pari
[Musique]
mais
il
[Musique]